hates to go and browse my name is Peter
Pan me cry and Ken are playing town Oh
Salem to show her support of the
beautiful game and they recently had a
Kickstarter check out their page but
also check out the game it's really fun
watch us play it
enjoy audience are you ready for town of
Salem this is ray william johnson rock
and someone explained this game now okay
thanks cry we're living in a town and
there's easy people they're gonna try to
kill us
they're serial killer they could just be
a monster but they're serial killers
just say it's like it's not a pious joy
there's so many pity pies I don't even
know who I am anymore oh my god I forgot
Beauty die pie pie pie
beaut okay so I'm you die pay I'm hush
puppy don't mind me look mom look at my
thank you oh honey pot I'm gonna
investigate Will Smith
good I'm gonna investigate this peach
pie guy I don't think I can trust him Oh
God
I was attacked by the serial killer
no none Will Smith Will Smith all right
I gotta vote for Beauty page no vote for
everyone that's not Peter peg
gotta save you puny Paige oh no not
patty pot this is terrible
what's your defense he said say some
funny memes monkey dance
don't don't Dec help it if I pick kill
him if they don't kill him
and it's innocent an innocent man I'm
good come on don't know oh yeah aquiline
so he's actually dead yeah do anything
wrong oh my god Betty
it's the weight fitted part now I'm dead
how do you know
cry your dad I'm rich with YouTube money
with your dying no no the real beauty
Pine Bush everyone would kill see Josh
Lucas has joined the tan I can talk with
the dead wow really yeah cool what well
it kind of small town in hell are we
gonna make it five nights for this [ __ ]
yeah okay okay let's work together all
right who are you okay I am leave it to
beef I'm uh [ __ ] footage [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm gonna kill Jon Hawthorne whoa
god I think I died that's crazy
oh no not John good I loved him George
Lucas click on you vote for him
everybody played for lowly I think Aloha
is it a medium somebody's talking to me
who is it Molly says he's in best
but now it's like your last night what
the [ __ ] do I do can you guys see this
shitty conversation no no good
oh god me just died it's loeli loeli
totally did it
I spoke to that spirit spoke to the
tense
yeah that's right Lola spoke to the dead
stop
I don't know if this is game throwing
put your stop I mean guilting the game
George Lucas I'm talking to loli when
he's dead loli how's hell treating you
I got nothing out of them
I'm the medium no that's not true
it can't be true I am the medium yeah
that's right
it was the framer I'm speaking to the
spirits excuse me what are the spirits
tell you it's beef what's is that what
they said yeah no my god that's a that's
ridiculous that's ridiculous I can't I
was attacked for the Mafia you better
lock your door tonight
no no wow
thanks again for town of salem huge
thanks again for town of salem to
getting us in the game go support the
card game version on their kickstarter
in the link down below i hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did leave in
like and as always stay awesome there we
go you know what I would take him